[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und marietta slomka guten abend im
sonderzug ins kriegsgebiet die
regierungschefs von polen tschechien und
slowenien sind heute nach kiew gereist
und präsident zielinski zu treffen das
ist schon eine sehr ungewöhnliche
initiative die ukrainische hauptstadt
wurde auch heute schwer beschossen die
russische armee rückt näher seit heute
abend gilt eine strikte ausgangssperre
man darf seine wohnung nur noch
verlassen um den luftschutzkeller und
bunker zu gehen petra otto fasst die
entwicklungen des tages zusammen
so hörte es sich an heute nacht irgendwo
in kiew
und so sah es aus als es tag wurde sie
können nur noch zuschauen wie das was
bislang ihr leben war plötzlich nicht
mehr ist
ich habe erwartet dass so was passieren
könnte aber es ist eine sache es zu
erwarten ganz anders ist es wenn es real
wird ganz anders
gestern haben wir gelöscht heute wieder
das ist so schwierig menschen sterben
und am schlimmsten ist es wenn kinder
sterben
die russische armee versucht wohl die
hauptstadt einzukesseln kiews
bürgermeister hat eine ausgangssperre
verhängt und eben dieses bekämpfte
unsichere gebiet da wagten sich heute
die regierungschefs aus polen tschechien
und slowenien hinein um ein zeichen zu
setzen ein erstes bild inzwischen sind
sie gut angekommen der tschechische
ministerpräsident hat wittert ziel des
besuchs ist dass die uneingeschränkte
unterstützung der europäischen union für
die ukraine und ihre freiheit und
unabhängigkeit zum ausdruck zu bringen
doch die angriffe gehen weiter kosten
menschen heimat und leben und doch
scheinen ukraine und russland um eine
lösung zu ring betonen
verhandlungsbereitschaft bei einer
militär konferenz in london der zellen
ski per video zugeschaltet und drückt
ein wenig ab vom anspruch einer nato
mitgliedschaft der ukraine
wir haben viele jahre lang gehört die
türen stünden uns offen aber wir haben
auch gehört dass wir nicht eintreten
können und das ist die wahrheit und die
müssen wir einfach akzeptieren
die schrecken des krieges sie nehmen
ihren lauf dieses video einer
ukrainischen
überwachungsdrohne wurde der zdf
redaktion frontal zugespielt zu sehen
nach angaben ukrainischer militärs die
erschießung eines zivilisten offenbar
durch russische soldaten
das russische verteidigungsministerium
zählt heute wieder auf was wo alles
abgeschossen und zerstört werden konnte
auch im süden des landes
die russischen streitkräfte übernahmen
die volle kontrolle über das gebiet rund
um herrschen hier in der gegend umher
sondern eine großstadt nahe am schwarzen
meer wollen die russen 6 thronen
abgeschossen haben und diese bilder von
angeblich zerstörten verlassenen
militärfahrzeugen die sollen das belegen
maxime kill darauf er kommt aus dieser
gegend und protestiert auf seine weise
gegen diesen krieg mit kunst mit
graffitis auf zerstörten panzern ein
hingucker
katrin eigendorf ist unsere reporterin
in der ukraine
katrin dieser besuch von da drei
osteuropäischen eu regierungschefs wie
kommt das an in der ukraine
das wird vor allem von regierungsseite
natürlich eine als eine geste großer
unterstützung angesehen denn für die
ukraine ist ja die perspektive auf eine
eu-mitgliedschaft unglaublich wichtig
das hat der präsident sie lenski immer
wieder ganz klar gesagt die ukraine
orientiert sich nach europa die ukraine
will eine integration in die nato
allerdings und das habe ich hier auch
bei vielen gesprächen mit der
bevölkerung bemerkt sagen viele menschen
mittlerweile es ist genug der gesten wir
wollen auch mal klare perspektiven sehen
das ist zwar eine große geste der
solidarität
sagen mir manche menschen hier aber was
ist denn nun wirklich mit konkreten
maßnahmen wir sehen uns als europäer ich
habe heute hier zum beispiel mit einem
opernsänger gesprochen der auch in
münchen lebende sagt ich bin von meiner
ganzen seele europäer wie wir ukraine
alle warum gebt ihr uns nicht eine klare
perspektive auf eine mitgliedschaft
du bist jetzt in odessa in der in der
haft stadt im süden wie ist da jetzt die
lage hinter dir sieht es jetzt am abend
sehr leer aus
ja also die lage ist heute eigentlich
muss man sagen wirklich ein bisschen
gespenstisch man sieht das vielleicht
jetzt hinter mir so sieht es hier
überall in der stadt aus wir haben
natürlich jetzt hier ausgangssperre aber
auch schon bevor die ausgangssperre hier
eingetreten ist war die stadt fast
menschenleer man geht davon aus es gibt
verschiedene informationen dass die
russische armee möglicherweise auch
odessa in kürze angreifen könnte die
stadt war ja bis jetzt noch nicht im
mittelpunkt des krieges gerückt aber man
hat sich hier die ganze zeit darauf
vorbereitet die innenstadt ist komplett
mit barrikaden durchzogen die menschen
haben hier panzersperren aufgebaut um
praktisch einen russischen vormarsch
verhindern zu können und das heißt
natürlich strategisch eine sehr wichtige
stadt für die ukraine es ist die
drittgrößte stadt und die wichtigste
hafenstadt des landes die menschen
bereiten sich darauf vor aber
interessanterweise bei allen mit denen
ich heute hier gesprochen habe ist der
widerstandsgeist eigentlich ungebrochen
viele haben die stadt verlassen aber die
die hier geblieben sind die sagen wir
werden hier bis zum schluss aus haben
und auch wenn die russische armee hier
einmarschiert auch wenn wir jetzt hier
angegriffen werden wir weichen nicht
zurück
kathrin danke dir für die eindrücke aus
odessa und für deine arbeit
was die russische armee in der ukraine
macht die massive zerstörung das
bombardieren von wohnquartieren und
krankenhäusern ohne rücksicht auf
verluste das weckt erinnerungen an den
tschetschenienkrieg und an den syrien
krieg städte wie grosny oder aleppo die
in schutt und asche gelegt wurden so wie
jetzt etwa die ukrainische hafenstadt
mario pohl was dort auf videos und
bildern zu sehen ist ist genau so
apokalyptisch
es gibt aber noch andere parallelen wie
goliath erläutert und der frage nachgeht
ob der russische kampfeinsatz in syrien
nicht auch eine bewusste vorbereitung
auf den ukraine krieg war
russische flaggen
russische kriegskind zeichen und
russische parolen aus moskaus propaganda
drehbuch aber wir sind in syrien
studenten und dozenten demonstrieren in
diesen tagen für wladimir putin eine
woche vor dem angriff auf kirche empfing
syriens machthaber baschar al-assad
russlands verteidigungsminister sergej
schukow wollte manöver inspizieren über
320 waffenarten also eigentlich alle
waffen sagte er habe russland in syrien
getestet als der krieg angefangen hat
frohlocken syrische milizen und
russische soldaten
sie malen den namen des ukrainischen
präsidenten selensky auf ein schwein
das camp etwa in nordsyrien
mit jedem tag krieg in der ukraine
kommen seine erinnerungen zurück
erinnerungen an russland syrien krieg
der arzt ayman easa denkt zurück an
router damaskus 2016 was er damals sah
in seinem feld krankenhaus sei so etwas
wie die apokalypse gewesen
zuerst bombardierten sie die schule dann
flohen die schüler und lehrer ins
krankenhaus warum man das krankenhaus
der einzige schutzraum im dorf als sie
sich sicher waren dass alle im
krankenhaus sind bombardierten sie es
alle hatten angst das geräusch der
vakuumpumpen der russischen jets
verbauen haft
es war der erste tag nach einem
waffenstillstand den russland verkündet
hatte als russische jets des krankenhaus
angriffen erinnert sich der arzt
die bombardierungen einer
entbindungsstation die streubomben die
sogenannten humanitären korridore in der
ukraine
alles erscheint dsa heute wie ein
zynisches tisch
ich habe bekannte verwandte die sind
damals durch diese korridore und seither
sind sie verhaftet ich weiß bis heute
nicht was mit ihnen geschah der syrische
regime verneint ihrer existenz
syrien war nicht nur ein testgebiet für
russische kriegstaktik nie sagt amit
kotányi es war ein test für einen
zweiten krieg den krieg der
desinformation
kotányi arbeitet für den syrischen
zivilschutz er befreit menschen aus
trümmern und filmt seine einsätze kaum
jemand wurde von russlands medien und
politikern mehr verleumdet als er und
seine kollegen der tag des
giftgasangriff auf die stadt karachi
hund 2017 hat sich in sein gedächtnis
ein zuerst kam die syrische luftwaffe
dann dass er ihn gas dann die russischen
jets
machten erst die hilfe für die opfer als
die flugzeuge zurück kamen 13 male
zielten sie direkt auf uns jedem war
klar damit wollten sie ihre verbrechen
verstecken und jeden augenzeugen
syrien alle die durch diese hölle gingen
hat putins neuer krieg in der ukraine
nicht überrascht
wenn die internationale gemeinschaft
damals russland etwas entgegengesetzt
hätte in syrien denn wäre das was wir
jetzt erleben nicht besiegt
blieb heute auch am 11 jahrestag des
aufstands rufen sie nach dem sturz eines
regimes das heute dankt russland
gefestigter denn je ist
dazu passt dass russland jetzt auch neue
syrische söldner anheuern auf die aber
tatsächlich in die ukraine kommen und
wie es ihnen dort ergehen würde steht
auf einem anderen blatt gegen eine
reguläre armee in einem völlig fremden
land am boden zu kämpfen bei
minustemperaturen könnte für den einen
oder anderen syrischen kämpfer
unangenehme überraschungen bereithalten
so wie ja auch die russen feststellen
dass sie es in der ukraine mit einer
anderen situation und anderen gegnern zu
tun haben als den syrien oder
tschetschenien dass die große russische
armee ist überhaupt nötig hat in fremden
ländern söldner anzuheuern ist
erstaunlich genug zumal putin eine
eigene inländische selten organisation
hat die sogenannte gruppe wagner die
laut westlichen geheimdiensten schon in
der ukraine aktiv sein soll was es damit
auf sich hat erklärt kamran zafira
sie gelten als brutal und skrupellos
sollen für kriegsverbrechen
verantwortlich sein verstörende bilder
der söldnergruppe wagner hier ein
propagandavideo die truppe gilt als
putins privatarmee und zuletzt auch in
der ukraine aktiv sein zu experten
genug beweise dafür dass das die gruppe
wagner in der ukraine aktiv ist und das
hauptziel ist letztlich
die reguläre armee zu unterstützen in
dem kampf der der viele opfer bedeuten
könnte und und gleichzeitig sind sie
ihnen sehr erfahren im häuserkampf im
eroberung von städten und es geht jetzt
darum so zu sagen die großen städte in
der ukraine zu erobern und da wird wird
wagen eine zentrale rolle spielen gründe
der wagner gruppe ist der unternehmer
und putin vertraute dimitri prego schien
mit seinem catering-unternehmen schaffte
es zum chef caterer des kreml spitzname
putins koch
als anführer der wagner truppe gilt dem
tribut hinein frühere agent und
glühender anhänger des komponisten
richard wagner der offensichtlich kein
problem mit nazi symbolik hat gaga setzt
sich vor allem aus ehemaligen militärs
zusammen zum teil aus dem kriminellen
umfeld
es gibt eine gewisse sympathie für für
die nazis für für auch für die für die
ss das zeigt sich in der symbolik auch
der der truppe und sie sind letztlich
dafür zuständig die schmutzigen jobs für
den für den kreml zu machen dinge die
die reguläre armee nicht tun würde die
wattner gruppe operiert weltweit
2014 war sie schon bei der russischen
annexion der krim aktiv in syrien hilft
sie die macht von staatschef assad zu
sichern
doch in afrika sind russisches söldner
im einsatz für afrikanische machthaber
und als stoßtrupp russischer interessen
es bietet eine möglichkeit in regionen
zurückzukehren geopolitisches denen man
lange weg war wie zb afrika wo wagner in
seiner art privat public partnership
wirtschaftlich vor ort sich selbst
finanziert aber im schlepptau russischer
politischer einfluss kommt und
innenpolitisch ist es eine möglichkeit
für die russische führung mit
unpopulären folgen dieser konflikte
umzugehen nämlich hohe gefallenen zahlen
unter den regulären soldaten zu
vermeiden die in russland nach
afghanistan und tschetschenien äußerst
unpopulär sind
und so kämpft eine gruppe mit einem
rechtsextremen anführer für putin der
ukraine
während putin als kriegsgrund vorgibt
die ukraine von nazis befreien zu wollen
die große frage wird sein ob der
sogenannte westen weiter zusammen steht
ob vor allem europa zusammen steht das
ist so selbstverständlich nicht
osteuropäische länder wie polen ärgern
sich beispielsweise sehr über die
deutsche zurückhaltung in sachen gas und
öl
außerdem gibt es in europa nach wie vor
putin freunde wie den ungarischen
regierungschef auf der unter anderem
nicht zulassen wollte dass waffen für
die ukraine durch sein land
transportiert werden britta hilpert
berichtet
das lied vom ritterlichen soldaten wärmt
ungarische herzen zum nationalfeiertag
und doch heute geht es um mehr dies ist
auf der start in die heiße
wahlkampfphase
zwei kundgebung erlebt budapest heute
die größere von orbans fidesz
eu-kritisch putin freundlich dafür
liebten seine anhänger in bisher bundes
krieg im nachbarland
und doch organs umfragewerte steigen und
dann fährst und umgang raushalten
verspricht
unser interesse ist es dass er nicht zum
bau von einem krieg von jemand anderen
werden da können wir nicht gewinnen aber
alles verlieren deshalb
schicken wir weder soldaten noch waffen
auf die schlachtfelder
doch der krieg zwingt orban zu
politischen neuinterpretationen erstens
ungarn nimmt nun flüchtlinge auf es
seien nachbarn so orban und viele
ukraine haben familiäre bindungen nach
ungarn und seien damit keine sogenannten
illegalen migranten
zum zweiten ungarn trägt eu sanktionen
gegen russland mit in der runde wunder
dass man kennt eurobonds abhängigkeiten
russland baut und finanziert in ungarn
ein neues atomkraftwerk putin schickte
impfstoffe und versprach orban erst
kürzlich billigeres gas
der eu-ratsvorsitzende makro erlebt in
versailles bands grenzen keine
sanktionen bei öl und gas keine
waffenlieferungen aus oder über ungarn
orban schaukelt weiter zwischen eu und
russland
sie sehen sich im wahlkampf ist das für
orban von vorteil denn ärgern posieren
als jemand der den frieden bewahrt der
sich nicht einmischen will und
gleichzeitig wirft er der opposition vor
das sie truppen und waffen ukraine
schicken wollten
orban schimpfte auf europa und
verbündete sich mit putin so die
anhänger des kandidaten der geeinten
opposition peter maffay hatte des
kriegsbeginns chancen aber als korrupter
machtzirkel stieß immer mehr ungarn auf
doch gegen die meist regierungstreue
presse und den krieg trinkt ja kaum noch
durch mit seiner botschaft
es gibt nur eine einzige gute wahl wir
müssen nicht in austin wählen sondern
europa
in 19 tagen wählen die ungarn viktor
orban hat die propagandaschlacht heute
schon mal gesungen ob europa mit seinem
basiert auch gewinnen würde ist eine
andere frage
und die stimmung in russland schwer
einzuschätzen ob sich in den eliten des
landes oder sogar hinter den mauern des
kreml widerstand gegen putins krieg
formiert was in armee oder geheimdienst
über diesen feldzug gedacht wird das ist
in der bevölkerung immer noch mutige
gibt die trotz aller repressionen
protestieren ist umso beeindruckender
während einer live nachrichtensendung
wurde gestern die redakteurin marina auf
sunny koffer mit ihrer protestaktion
weltberühmt sie wurde danach verhaftet
ist jetzt aber vorerst wieder auf freiem
fuß heute äußerte sie sich nach einer
gerichtsverhandlung
sie sagte sie sei mehr als 14 stunden
verhört worden durfte keine verwandten
kontaktieren und tadel keinen
rechtsbeistand bekommen ihre lage sei
sehr schwierig gewesen
unklar wie es mit ihr weitergeht was
kreml-kritiker blühen kann zeigte ja
unter anderem der fall navalny besonders
krass mit einer meldung dazu beginnen
jetzt die nachrichten von günter gaus
die russische staatsanwaltschaft hat
eine weitere haftstrafe für alexej
nawalny gefordert noch einmal dreizehn
jahre gefängnis wegen angeblichen
betrugs und missachtung eines gerichts
derzeit sitzt der oppositionelle eine
haftstrafe von zweieinhalb jahren ab
nach dem giftanschlag auf ihn im sommer
2020 soll er gegen bewährungsauflagen
verstoßen haben navalny und seine
verbündeten weisen alle vorwürfe als
politisch motiviert zurück
angesichts des russischen
angriffskrieges in europa hat die
wehrbeauftragte des bundestages eva högl
in ihrem jahresbericht die dringende
beseitigung der ausstattungs mängel bei
der bundeswehr gefordert sie sei
entsetzt über die sogar bei
auslandseinsätzen bestehenden
ausrüstungs probleme zum teil betrage
die einsatzbereitschaft von großgeräten
nur knapp 50 prozent eine gute nachricht
sei dass geplante 100 milliarden euro
sondervermögen das zügig und sinnvoll
eingesetzt werden müsse mit einem zehn
punkte plan will die bundesregierung
effektiver gegen rechtsextremismus
vorgehen der maßnahmenkatalog sieht
unter anderem eine leichtere entwaffnung
von rechtsextremisten vor
bundesinnenministerium feser erklärte
ziel sei rechte netzwerke zu zerschlagen
und hetze im netz konsequenter zu
verfolgen der opposition gehen die
maßnahmen nicht weit genug
der ausstoß von treibhausgasen ist in
deutschland im vergangenen jahr wieder
deutlich gestiegen vor allem beim
hausbau bei der sanierung alter gebäude
und im verkehr wurden die
klimaschutzziele stark verfehlt nach
vorläufigen zahlen von umweltbundesamt
und klimaschutz ministerium wurden
insgesamt 4,5 prozent mehr treibhausgase
freigesetzt
nach einem rückgang um acht prozent im
corona jahr 2020 das ministerium
kündigte ein sofortprogramm für
schnelleren klimaschutz an
die korona zahlen steigen weiter knapp
200.000 neu getestete fälle heute die
dunkelziffer dunkelziffer dürfte viel
höher sein die bundesweite incidents bei
1585 so hoch wie noch nie und es gibt
283 neu gemeldete tote das scheint jetzt
wohl die neue normalität zu sein diese
woche berät der bundestag über eine
allgemeine impfpflicht wenn sie
überhaupt kommen wäre das ein thema für
den nächsten herbst schon ab morgen gilt
aber die teil impfpflicht für
medizinisches personal und pflegeberufe
doch es hapert an der umsetzung und es
gibt wieder einmal große föderale
unterschied oliver deuker berichtet
caritas haus st anna im bayrischen
holzkirchen fast 90 prozent der
mitarbeiter sind geimpft doch viele hier
sehen die ab morgen geltende
einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht
skeptisch auf der einen seite werden wir
gute engagierte mitarbeitende verlieren
die aus welcher überzeugung auch immer
sich nicht impfen lassen und meine noch
viel größere befürchtung ist dass es uns
noch schwieriger wird neue mitarbeitende
zu gewinnen so sieht es auch der leiter
des pflege wohnstifts daten steht in
hannover wo laut gesetz ungeimpfte
besucher schon mit einem negativen
schnell test ins haus dürfen der ist für
das personal sowieso tägliche pflicht
über 98 prozent der 121 mitarbeiter sind
hier geimpft 2 das ab
majors morgen die beiden personen ich
gehe davon aus dass wird einen längeren
zeitraum in anspruch nehmen dass sich
eine rückmeldung kriege je nachdem wie
die rückmeldung ausfällt wenn es in
richtung beschäftigungsverbot geht dann
muss ich sie freistellen sagen krise
auch kein geld mehr und müssen zu hause
bleiben leider die praktische umsetzung
der einrichtungs bezogenen impfpflicht
liegt bei den gesundheitsämtern die
schon jetzt am anschlag arbeiten es in
einzelfallentscheidungen es gibt fristen
festgelegte abläufe die von bundesland
zu bundesland variieren die richtung ist
aber gleich die gesundheitsbehörde
selber kann dann aber bußgelder
verhängen und über extremfall auch ein
beschäftigungsverbot ansprechen wenn es
tatsächlich zur beschäftigung verboten
kommt dann haben wir natürlich
arbeitsrechtlich ein riesenproblem und
müssen das wahrscheinlich in den meisten
fällen richtig lösen jetzt können also
monate ins land gehen für ungeimpfte
mitarbeiter bedeutet das
die dürfen weiterhin natürlich in ihrer
einrichtung arbeiten bis das verfahren
abgeschlossen ist und es wird dringend
darum gebeten und das hat dann auch der
entsprechende arbeitgeber
einrichtungsleiter sicherzustellen dass
sie nicht in den kontakt mit patienten
oder beispielsweise in einem altenheim
in kontakt mit bewohnern kommen pflegen
ohne menschen kontakt eine rätselhafte
empfehlung des gesetzgebers die auf
unverständnis trifft das funktioniert
nicht jeder mitarbeiter wird gebraucht
und ich kann nicht viel über monate
sagen du darfst jetzt nicht fliegen was
soll er machen pflegekraft silvia visa
ist nicht geimpft fühlt sich unnötig
unter druck gesetzt
unsicherheit ist da und angst da wie es
weitergeht
beschlossen wurde das gesetz um die
variablen gruppen zu schützen in der
praxis zeigt sich aber am tag vor dem
start es ist schwierig
die pandemie hat auf so vielen ebenen
schwere schäden verursacht sie hat vor
allem sehr viele leben gekostet bereits
mehr als
125.000 menschen hierzulande werden vom
rk ii als crooner todesfälle gezählt
noch nicht bekannt ist wie viele
menschen an den langzeitfolgen einer
infektion leiden werden teils nicht mehr
berufs fähig sind nach einschätzung von
experten sind dass viele auf der anderen
seite haben die eindämmung maßnahmen
natürlich auch schwere nebenwirkungen
gehabt nicht nur wirtschaftliche und
auch da zeigte sich wieder einmal die
schwächsten trifft es besonders
zb kinder die es beim schulischen lernen
eh schon schwerer haben dort fern
die wörter an der tafel lesen bei romy
geht das schnell und fehlerfrei
aber so flüssig wie romy lesen längst
nicht alle hier die düsseldorfer
zweitklässler kennen schule nur in
pandemie zeiten viele wochen waren sie
nicht in der klasse und nun lernen sie
mit maske das alles hat folgen für ihre
lesefähigkeit sagt die lehrerin
die sind einfach schwächer die können
auch nicht kleine texte erfassen wir
sind jetzt noch bei setzen und ich würde
sagen im vergleich zu anderen vorgängen
war ich zu diesem zeitpunkt was im
zweiten halbjahr des schuljahres reich
weiter das gefühl trügt nicht bei
viertklässlern fehlt laut einer
repräsentativen studie durchschnittlich
ein halbes schuljahr an lesefähigkeit
und im vergleich zu 2016 ist die zahl
der schwachen leser von 22 auf 28
prozent gestiegen die der starken leser
von 44 auf 37 prozent gesunken
wir können aber auch beobachten dass
bestimmte gruppen besonders betroffen
sind das betrifft zum einen kinder die
ihr ungünstigere lernbedingungen zu
hause haben also zum beispiel keinen
eigenen schreibtisch keinen
internetanschluss in der familie oder
auch kinder mit migrationshintergrund
sinnerfassend lesen fällt immer mehr
kindern schwer und kindern aus sozial
benachteiligten familien noch schwerer
ein corona auf wohl programm des bundes
soll helfen zwei milliarden euro für
extra förderung
dabei bleibt unterricht in der schule
das ziel
die studie zeigt nochmal eindringlich
dass es nicht mehr zu einem
flächendeckenden unterrichtsausfall
kommen darf lesen ist wie schreiben
rechnen eine grundkompetenz für den
weiteren bildungsweg deswegen muss
präsenzunterricht möglich sein die
pandemie und die schulen da gilt was
schon immer ein problem war ist jetzt
erst recht 1 vor allem der mangel an
lehrkräften so schnell sind keine neuen
lehrerinnen und lehrer ausgebildet
wir brauchen in den schulen
unterstützung durch multiprofessionelle
teams das heißt andere berufsgruppen die
die ich die die lehrkräfte in den
schulen unterstützen und entlasten
können damit sich die lehrkräfte auf
ihre eigentlichen aufgaben bilden und
erziehen oder auch förderung der
lesekompetenz
konzentrieren können lesen lernen so
schnell wie möglich lehrerinnen erzieher
ehrenamtliche sind jetzt gemeinsam
gefragt
und jetzt nochmal grunde land zum
nächsten nachrichten aus der wirtschaft
ja da kommt die nachricht des tages aus
der halbleiterindustrie
der us-konzern intel will in magdeburg
eine chip fabrik bauen das ist eine
milliardeninvestition in sachsen anhalt
nach dem interview in ganz europa nach
standorten gesucht hatte valerie haller
warum wurde es nun magdeburg ja weil
scheinbar vieles einfach passt
beispielsweise die zentrale lage
zwischen tesla und volkswagen das sind
ja potenziell wichtige kunden
forschungseinrichtungen und fachkräfte
und außerdem lockt jede menge geld von
stadt land bund und auch von der eu sie
will europa nämlich unabhängiger machen
von chips aus asien für magdeburg sprach
auch dass es jede menge platz gibt im
südwesten der stadt akkar rund
620 fußballfelder groß genug für zwei
werke 17 milliarden euro investiert
intel schafft 3000 arbeitsplätze und
noch einige tausende mehr bei
lieferanten in der region
die erwartungen sind groß
wir schaffen den rahmen und das sich
inter sozusagen für deutschland und für
sachsen-anhalt entschieden hat ist für
uns eine botschaft die für uns noch
nicht mal fassbar ist aber in ihrer
dimension durchaus schon absehbar mitten
in der aktuellen chip krise geht der us
konzern voll auf expansionskurs in den
nächsten zehn jahren will intel mehr als
380 milliarden euro in europa
investieren in magdeburg drücken alle
schon aufs tempo bis die ersten
deutschen chips in produktion gehen
dauert noch vermutlich bis 20 27 vor
allem autohersteller könnten profitieren
ihr hunger nach chips ist riesig valerie
haller vielen dank
altkanzler gerhard schröder verzichtet
auf die ehrenbürgerwürde der stadt
hannover und kommt damit der geplanten
aufhebung der würde zuvor infolge des
russischen angriffskrieges geriet
schröder wegen seiner freundschaft zu
wladimir putin in die kritik auch in
seiner heimatstadt an deutschen
flughäfen sind erneut zahlreiche flüge
ausgefallen wegen der warnstreiks des
sicherheitspersonals zu denen die
gewerkschaft verdi aufgerufen hatte
morgen gehen die tarifverhandlungen
weiter nach drei erfolglosen runden wäre
die fordert mindestens einen euro mehr
pro stunde für die sicherheitskräfte
das was von uns online halbwissen
natürlich durchgehend über aktuelle
entwicklungen auf dem laufenden auf zdf
folgt und hier meldet sich christopher
wehrmann um 0.15 mit unserem
heute-journal update darin ein interview
mit grünen-parteichefin ricarda lang zum
krieg in der ukraine und gleich hatte
wetter geht es aber erstmal weiter mit
der reportage reihe 37 grad auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
schon gute und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter es lag heute etwas in der luft
und zwar saharastaub und er wurde aus
nordafrika zu uns geführt schuld daran
ist dieses tief hier vor spanien und
nordafrika es dreht sich gegen den
uhrzeigersinn und schaufel den
saharastaub nach norden und auch die
wärme und so gab es in süddeutschland
sah staub richtung frankreich biskaya
aber auch über spanien
ja und die nächsten tage da kommt etwas
regen auf am donnerstag das wird nicht
viel sein danach stabilisiert sich ein
massives hoch und zwar wird es ein wert
von gut 1000 50 hektopascal erreichen in
der nacht zieht der regen allmählich ab
und zwar nach osten und unlocker des auf
es bildet sich teilweise nebel und die
temperaturen sinken auf minus zwei grad
im hessischen bergland und plus sieben
grad im südosten deutschlands
morgen dann erst einmal viele wolken die
ziehen allmählich ab und dann kommt die
sonne hervor aber der sahara staub kann
uns durchaus einen strich durch die
rechnung machen und dann bleibt es
länger trüb und die temperaturen könnten
auch gedämpft werden die werte morgen
bei 7 grad richtung ostsee häufig 14 15
17 grad ganz im westen und 19 im
südwesten richtung oberrhein die
nächsten tage am donnerstag gibt es
regen der zieht einmal nach osten es
wird nicht viel sagen temperaturen bis
18 grad und freitag und samstag wird es
dann immer sonniger damit ein schöner
abend